اسمح لي ان اعلق على هذه الصور التي
نشاهدها الان لسقوط صواريخ اذن في الجليل
الاعلى كما ذكرنا استهداف لمناطق في
الداخل وايضا هناك اصابه لمنشاه في نهاريا
كما ذكر مراسلنا واسرائيلي
اصيب بجراح طفيفه بحسب المعلومات القبه
الحديديه تصدت لعدد من الصواريخ ولكنها لم
تتصدى لكل الصواريخ منها وقع او وصل الى
البحر ايضا اجتماع
نتنياهو الان مع الوزراء ووزير الدفاع كلف
بالرد الاولي من خلال اطلاق قذائف بالفعل
تم اطلاقها على لبنان ليس هناك اي معلومات
حتى الان ان كان هناك اصابات في الجانب
اللبناني بحسب التصريحات فان الاستهداف
بالقذائف المدفعيه الاسرائيليه استهدف
المناطق المفتوحه التي من المتوقع ان يكون
منها قد تم اطلاق صواريخ مصادر اسرائيليه
كانت تتحدث عن 50 صاروخ او بالاحرى 100
صاروخ خلال 10 دقائق مراسل العربيه الان
يؤكد ان المعلومات تشير الى 50 صاروخ خلال
ربع ساعه